of all the players in this event who do
you think has the best advantage going
from a rapid and blitz event straight to
a classical maybe I'll say and Fabiano
Caruana because I think I have a feeling
that in general he usually starts slow
in the early rounds of the tournament
and it's very beneficial for those who
start to have that necessary warmup
I'm normally a player who starts slow
maybe I'll benefit mostly for me it is
Sergey Kuryakin because you play
normally every time same openings and I
mean for him is not big difference he
prefers to play rapid beats or first
classical I think this problem bleeds
it's taking a lot of energy so if after
that you have classical event then it
could be a bit tricky for the older the
older players but in rapid and blitz
you're a bit more experimental mode and
you get to fool around a bit more before
the classical starts and I think that's
probably and if you get off to a good
start in the rapid blitz then that can
you might carry that positive feeling
over first you have to know if a player
will be successful in the wrapped in
boots event and and that's always a
toss-up nobody is guaranteed of high
placing the players who do better in the
problem boots will have more confidence
for the classical network my carry over
I think most of us would like to play
the classical and then play the rapid
you play this long event and then if you
don't have a really good tournament you
get to have fun thank you you get the
chance to quickly regain your positions